[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: So you're
developing an app.
And of course, that app is
innovative and groundbreaking.
It has huge potential.
And if it's as
successful as you expect,
it may one day exceed the
limits of traditional systems.
You'll need a
NoSQL database that
is fast, simple to maintain,
and scales from gigabytes
to petabytes with no downtime.
That's where Google Cloud
Bigtable comes into play.
Cloud Bigtable is a
fully managed service,
meaning you can
concentrate on your app
instead of tuning your database.
With its unique
combination of low latency
and high throughput,
Cloud Bigtable
can scale to reliably
handle massive workloads
at lightning-fast speeds,
and up to millions
of operations per second with
no reconfiguration downtime.
Customers are using
Cloud Bigtable today
for a range of applications,
from real-time ad analytics
all the way to tracking
millions of readings
from thousands of IoT sensors.
And because Cloud Bigtable
is compatible with industry
standard tools like
HBase, Hadoop, and Google
BigQuery and Cloud
Dataflow, it means
it's easy to put all that
data to work for your app.
Google Cloud Bigtable-- the
super fast, highly scalable,
NoSQL database your app
needs today and tomorrow.